twenty-three percent that's the figure
of young people out of work in Europe
today so what do young people really
think about Europe well we're at the yo
fest in Brussels let's find out I just
don't believe in the whole Parliament
ear people don't trust politicians and
that's why German salty young people
don't trust existing politicians
followed the YouTube just behaving like
a consumer and trying to be a consumer
politics is not good enough politics is
about democracy and this is not only
about choice but about getting involved
sorry the weather was miserable but that
didn't put off young people it seemed
the festival was getting into full swing
with music and even my MERS hello do you
like today's event and do you think it's
gonna help young people does it anger
you that so many young people in Europe
are out of work today youth unemployment
has skyrocketed in countries like Italy
Greece and Spain the European Social
Fund and the six billion year youth
guarantee scheme show politicians are
trying to help Europe is our only chance
to have a better future and that's why I
encourage young people all over Europe
to get involved to ensure your voices
are heard loud and clear over to the
President of the European Youth Forum
which had helped put on this event what
was his message you simply have to
decide for herself do I want to make a
change do I want to be a change maker I
want to go out and vote and do things
and change things I want to go out into
my community and help my fellow
colleagues I believe in solidarity I
want to take part events like the ofs
may not be an instant band-aid for the
problems facing today's youth but
despite the rain there was hope for the
future I hope the current politicians
are doing everything possible to plan
something in the future for the next
20-30 years so when he becomes in 20s it
doesn't have to be one of the unemployed
people